i think one of the reasons that i got a
bit of pushback about that meta
is i think that a lot of people who
exercise quite a bit um
want to believe that that
picks all of the uh activity related
boxes when it comes to overall health um
and i think there's a reason that people
want to believe that like i want to
believe that i have a sedentary job i
work on a computer uh you know i go for
a few walks i lift weights i play some
basketball
but
i mean eight hours a day i'm sitting on
my ass uh reading writing typing
whatever um so i
i very much want to think that that is
not having deleterious general health
effects it probably is um i don't know
what i gained from lying to myself about
that um
but yeah so i think that's one of the
reasons why there was a bit of pushback
like um
you know if you have an office job and
you go work out for an hour every day
after work but maybe you're only
averaging three four thousand steps per
day um
you don't
necessarily want to think that because
it takes a while to get steps in you
know like if you if you
live in a commuter culture where there's
not great public transit
you're driving an hour to and from work
every day you work a sedentary job boom
there's 10 hours of the day gone uh you
sleep eight hours a night boom there's
18 hours of the day gone now you got six
hours left you need to eat some meals
you want to spend some time with loved
ones you have some hobbies uh and you
know if you want to work in
ten thousand steps it's some at some
point in that process uh that aren't
facilitated by your lifestyle like if
you don't live in a walkable city or
something like that um
you know it's gonna take a while like
it's gonna take a significant time
investment to get those steps in
and so
it would be
great
if that wasn't necessary and you could
just go to the gym for an hour boom now
you've checked all of those boxes um but
at least my my read of the literature is
that that is not the case
that just overall general activity
levels with step counts being a pretty
good proxy for that um
does seem to be not only a
predictor of of general health and
longevity but probably a causal factor
as well um and yeah it would be i would
love if that was not the case uh and for
for years i told myself that that wasn't
the case um
but yeah as as i've got into this
literature more i've uh unfortunately
for myself changed my mind about that